[Music]
Amandla cludes sharing an emotional
tribute to her late husband Nick Cordero
who died on Sunday following a three
month battle with kovat 19 complications
the video was put together by Amanda's
sister and occludes
[Music]
the moving six-minute montage features
touching moments between Amanda and neck
throughout their five-year romance the
couple had met while starring together
in bullets over Broadway in 2014
Nick received a Tony nomination for his
performance amanda captioned the video
he would always look at me and say i'm
the luckiest well darling I was the
luckiest to get to spend five years with
you and to share a son that will always
remind me of you
amanda has also been sharing videos of
Nick with their one-year-old son Elvis
and she captioned this new video things
that are helping me right now
amanda has received an outpouring of
support since the beginning of Nick's
hospitalization in March which she
chronicled on social media sharing
important health updates about Nick life
throws so many things at you and you
never know what that is there were days
that I did not think I could get on this
social media and and sing but I always
felt better after I did again guys thank
you so much for all your support on
Monday amanda opened up about nick's
final moments nick left this earth with
people around him but he loved listening
to music i don't i don't think he would
have wanted anything else so i think we
gave him a good send-off and elvis of
every day of my life that's for sure
support has also come from their close
friend and bullets over Broadway co-star
Zach Braff Zach shared a tribute to Nick
after his death on Sunday and he
revealed an intimate message he received
from his friend the last thing he ever
texted me was to look out for his wife
and one-year-old son Elvis I promised
the world they will never want for
anything I feel so incredibly grateful I
got to have Nick
Derro enter my life
[Music]